and also these snacks are really easy to
eat on the go
i don't know where i'm going
so today we're going to be talking about
what i eat in a day i've seen a lot of
your comments i've seen how excited and
interested you are about nutrition i'm
going to be showing you exactly what i
ate yesterday most of it's not home
cooked it's not fancy but it is
nutritious and it's food that i
genuinely enjoy it's time for me to go
into the hospital it's going to be a
crazy day because i'm starting super
early and i have a really late day but
when it's a gorgeous day like this it
definitely makes it a lot easier so for
breakfast today i'm doing one of my
favorites
avocado toast with a little smoked
salmon get your essential fatty asses in
it
so good
okay you wanna bite
you wanna bite
no for me breakfast i got all the syrup
i got i got all the syrup it's known as
the most important meal of the day but
not everybody wakes up with an appetite
so i understand if breakfast isn't for
everyone but if you do eat breakfast
you're getting a lot of health benefits
throughout the day not only do you
kick-start your metabolism which allows
you to burn calories throughout the day
but you're also giving yourself enough
energy to get to the gym first
ingredient very simple whole wheat bread
i really enjoy whole wheat bread versus
white bread whole wheat bread contains
complex carbohydrates versus simple
carbohydrates that you find in white
bread what it does is it gives you
energy to be utilized throughout the day
instead of just giving you one quick
peek and then a crash later on and
sometimes get into that hangry state
that we all know about
the meatloaf next like cream cheese you
need saturated fat to make hormones in
your body and while it does raise bad
cholesterol it also raises good
cholesterol next ingredient my favorite
ingredient avocados avocado is actually
the aztec word for testicle because
avocados do hang in pairs with one
hanging lower than the other so they do
resemble testicles pretty cool fact they
contain a lot of antioxidants and
they're rich in fiber yes avocado does
contain a lot of fat but it's important
to remember that it's unsaturated fat
and that unsaturated fat actually helps
increase your good cholesterol and does
not affect your bad cholesterol lastly
we have salmon it's a great ingredient
to add to your meals because it contains
proteins omega-3s antioxidants and on
top of everything else it's delicious
[Music]
it's snack time i just finished rounds i
have to go to research today need a
snack
lunch is still a good three hours away
i really like the perfect bar because
made of good quality ingredients i'm not
their spokesperson but i'm definitely a
big fan they contain a lot of protein
they're made with good quality
ingredients and because they have to be
refrigerated you know there's no
preservatives
it's lunch time just got my favorite
meal for lunch right here little
chipotle action
i'm eating with my colleagues here say
hello colleagues
they say hi while some doctors go to the
cafeteria if i'm not on call i like to
get out of the hospital for a bit so i
do run out to chipotle it's one of my
favorite places to get lunch i really
like the ingredients that they use i
think they're really tasty and what i
really enjoy is that you're in control
you get to choose what ingredients go
into your plate i really like to get a
burrito bowl instead of a burrito or a
quesadilla because it avoids some of the
extra carbohydrates that you get from
getting a wrap but the things that i do
like to make is to get a burrito bowl
with either chicken or steak both high
in protein there's been a lot said about
eating red meat and increases risk of
cancer and while that's true in high
amounts if you eat in moderate amounts
in a good balance that's obviously not a
problem we have black beans they are
zero fat and they're one of the richest
foods in fiber which actually allows you
to decrease some of the bad cholesterol
that you can get through eating an
unhealthy diet brown rice brown rice is
definitely superior to white rice it's a
complex carbohydrate it doesn't peak
your sugar level like white rice does
next i like to go for guacamole they
always say do you know that it's extra
and i always say yeah i do but well
worth it i get the mild salsa because
i'm not a fan of my food being too spicy
last but not least i
love cheese gives you a little bit of
calcium a little bit of vitamin d
overall this is a nutritious meal for
someone that shares my goals and trying
to keep weight on and build muscle you
have a good mix of complex carbohydrates
proteins vitamins fiber all great
nutrients but it's important to note
that these meals do contain a lot of
sodium chipotle is known for that and
now they started putting their sodium
content on the menus so keep that in
mind because excess sodium can put extra
pressure on your heart and kidneys i am
an athlete and the rest of my day i
don't take in much sodium
so i think it's a great meal for me but
just again keep that in mind that the
sodium content and this meal is high
[Music]
do you know what time it is
it's snack time again
got my carrots and nuts
perfect healthy snack what's beautiful
about these almonds right here is that
they contain vitamin e fiber they keep
your hair nails looking fresh
the carrot
you know you know i love carrots carrots
are rich in vitamin a known as
beta-carotene almonds grape unsaturated
fats vitamin e great a boutique for
healthy hair nails and skin and in
general i just think that they're fun to
eat
[Music]
is there a doctor in the house just
ordered some sushi
crazy day in the hospital but gotta get
my protein in got to get my omega-3
fatty acids i like to get a variety of
sushi and i get the real sushi not the
sushi that people eat with the rolls and
all that just fish on top of brown rice
very clean it's really my favorite meal
to end the day get ready for the next
day without overeating and feeling fully
stuffed when i go to bed this is my
go-to dinner meal i love fish i love the
omega-3s that they provide there's not a
lot of calories in here i prefer eating
my sushi with brown rice we talked about
the benefits earlier you get complex
carbohydrates you get proteins it's a
clean meal it fills you up and really it
does taste great important to note about
fish
wild fish is better than farm fish
because it contains less mercury there's
a lot of news going around about how
mercury poisoning is bad so if you are
eating farmed fish make sure no more
than three to four servings a week so
that's what i actually eat in a day and
it's not something that i eat every day
i know yesterday i consumed probably
more sodium that i should have but in
general it's balanced it's in moderation
and that's really the smart way to go
this diet obviously does not work for
everybody and i don't recommend it for
everybody if you're interested in the
calories and all the other nutrients
that were in my meals check out the
description down below we put all that
information there for you and remember
eat in moderation to stay healthy
[Music]
hey guys thanks for watching if you
haven't already hit that subscribe
button now to get new videos every week